Lucia: 还是二楼的客厅要装饰
Lucia: Or the second floor living room too?
Jake: 就一楼吧
Jake: Just the first floor.
Jake: 然后还有各位的房间
Jake: And everyone's rooms too.
Jake: 我可能找个时间
Jake: I'll find some time...
Jake: 今天或者明天或者等你们收拾好
Jake: Today or tomorrow, or after you guys tidy up.
Jake: 总之就是
Jake: Anyway...
Jake: 这几天我会把整个房子用iPhone扫一遍
Jake: I'll scan the whole house with my iPhone in the next few days.
Jake: 嗯然后各位的卧室就收拾收拾
Jake: Yeah, and you guys can tidy up your bedrooms.
Jake: 对要扫进去
Jake: Yes, it needs to be scanned.
Lucia: 那你要不扫之前通知一声
Lucia: Let me know before you scan.
Lucia: 这样我就可以在扫之前
Lucia: So I can pull up the box before you scan.
Lucia: 把那个箱子拉起来
Lucia: And get it out of the way.
Alice: 薇薇
Alice: Tasha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你困啦
Tasha: Are you sleepy?
Alice: 我还不困
Alice: I'm not sleepy yet.
Lucia: 我这没口袋这个东西
Lucia: I don't have a pocket for this thing.
Lucia: 要不然把它拔了
Lucia: Should I just unplug it?
Lucia: 哈哈呃
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 你看一下它有多少电
Jake: Check how much battery it has.
Jake: 如果电很多的话没关系
Jake: If it has a lot, it's fine.
Lucia: 哦我在手机上能看
Lucia: Oh, I can check it on my phone.
Lucia: 到它有多少电
Lucia: See how much battery it has.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Alright.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice: 又找到他在这
Alice: Found him here again.
Lucia: 93%是不是应该可以拔
Lucia: 93%, should be fine to unplug, right?
Jake: 可以OK
Jake: Yeah, it's OK.
Jake: 对你坐着的时候充嘛
Jake: You can charge it while sitting.
Jake: 然后站着就
Jake: And then...
Tasha: 就还剩这些最后这
Tasha: So, these are the last ones.
Tasha: 最后一二三四五六六块没有
Tasha: Only one, two, three, four, five, six pieces left.
Tasha: 找着家了
Tasha: Found their home.
Alice: 看看像不像
Alice: Let's see if it matches.
Tasha: 嗯像
Tasha: Hmm, it does.
Tasha: 但不一定他们俩在一起感觉
Tasha: But they might not feel right together.
Jake: 来这边
Lucia: 他怎么突然变成network Arrow了
Lucia: How did he suddenly become Network Arrow?
Jake: 啊我看一下
Jake: Ah, let me take a look.
Jake: 可以给我看一下吗
Jake: Can I see it?
Lucia: 对就是在我把电拔掉之后
Lucia: Yeah, it happened after I unplugged it.
Lucia: 他突然变成这个界面了
Lucia: It suddenly switched to this screen.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah
Lucia: 这个是什么意思
Lucia: What does this mean?
Shure:  你先把这几个字这个
Jake: 重开一下
Jake: Restart it.
Jake:我也没见过这个
Jake: I've never seen this either.
Lucia: 就我把它这样
Lucia: So, I'll just do this.
Lucia: 就是这样关掉重开一下什么情况
Lucia: Just shut it down and restart, what's going on?
Shure:  先先先来这个先先把一根给一边
Shure: First, first, give this one to the side.
Shure:  给那什么
Shure: To what?
Jake: 好我这出不来
Jake: Okay, I can't get this out.
Shure:  你把那缩一下
Shure: Shrink that.
Tasha: 这样这个猪就塞不下他
Tasha: So, this pig can't fit in.
Jake: 这个长度是对的吗
Jake: Is this length correct?
Katrina:  都一样的
Katrina: They're all the same.
Shure:  都是一样
Shure: They're all the same.
Katrina:  对一下
Katrina: Check it.
Lucia: 啊出来了他应该还是正常的吧
Lucia: Ah, it's back to normal, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 可能是刚才有什么bug了
Lucia: Maybe there was a bug just now.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 或者装饰二楼
Jake: Or decorate the second floor.
Jake: 因为二楼的那个场地
Jake: Because the space on the second floor.
Jake: 就做PPT比较方便
Jake: It's more convenient for doing PPTs.
Jake: 就是就可以摆那个
Jake: So we can arrange those.
Jake: 摆摆椅子
Jake: Arrange chairs.
Jake: 摆很多椅子
Jake: Arrange a lot of chairs.
Lucia: 哦对对
Lucia: Oh, right, right.
Lucia: 因为二楼的桌子太像那个椅子了
Tasha: 太像椅子了
Jake: 对所以在二楼装饰
Jake: Yeah, so we decorated the second floor.
Tasha: 他们这家该放哪里呢
Tasha: Where should they place this family?
Shure:  脑血栓
Alice: 哈哈但我觉得他俩又不像一家
Alice: Haha, but I don't think they look like a family.
Alice: 因为这个角不太好拼
Alice: Because this corner is hard to fit.
Alice: 就比较尖的角
Alice: It's a pretty sharp corner.
Alice: 有没有比较尖的角
Alice: Is there a sharper corner?
Tasha: 他的嘴是吗
Tasha: His mouth, right?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake: 剩了一圈了
Jake: There's one lap left.
Jake: 这一圈很强
Jake: This lap is really strong.
Lucia: 但是感觉只有
Lucia: But it feels like only
Lucia: 只有这几个是比较确定的
Lucia: Only these few are more certain.
Lucia: 我们找到了很多两个
Lucia: We found many pairs.
Lucia: 两个是一起的
Lucia: Two together.
Tasha: 找到了好朋友
Tasha: Found good friends.
Lucia: 但是确定了放在哪里
Lucia: But not sure where to place them.
Tasha: 但是找不到他们的家
Tasha: But can't find their home.
Jake: 好多好朋友
Jake: So many good friends.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun.
Lucia: 哇哎这个真的好一致啊
Lucia: Wow, this is really consistent.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my god.
Lucia: 这个你是怎么找到的
Lucia: How did you find this?
Tasha: 他这有两个尖尖
Tasha: It has two points.
Tasha: 这两个尖尖
Tasha: These two sharp points.
Jake: 我去这尖尖你能看到
Jake: Wow, you can see those points?
Jake: 眼神真好
Jake: Great eyesight.
Jake: 我这看不清
Jake: I can't see clearly.
Tasha: 哦这个弧度我之前看到过
Tasha: Oh, I've seen this curve before.
Jake: 有点6
Jake: Impressive.
Shure:  人生的最后7天
Shure: The last 7 days of life.
Shure:  来吧立起来
Shure: Come on, stand it up.
Lucia: 会不会是那个鸟翅膀
Lucia: Could it be that bird's wing?
Shure:  哦还有一个是吗
Shure: Oh, there's another one, right?
Shure:  对还有一个
Shure: Yeah, there's another one.
Shure:  还有这个
Shure:  给
Shure: Here you go.
Lucia: 完美
Lucia: Perfect.
Lucia: 哎棒棒
Lucia: Oh, awesome.
Tasha: 棒棒
Tasha: Awesome.
Tasha: 那说明鸟不在边边
Tasha: That means the bird isn't on the edge.
Lucia: 诶这个
Lucia: Hey, this...
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: This one, this one.
Lucia: 感觉这个弧度很像
Lucia: Feels like this curve is very similar.
Lucia: 很像哎
Lucia: Very similar, huh.
Jake: 确实有点像
Jake: It does look a bit similar.
Lucia: 哎对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Lucia: 这个也是对的
Lucia: This one's right too.
Jake: 这是你记住的吗
Jake: Is this what you remembered?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Katrina:  再拿一个是吗
Lucia: 这儿进去吗
Lucia: Does this go in here?
Alice: 像又不太像这个头
Alice: It looks similar but not quite like this head.
Lucia: 诶我们刚才是不是给这个蛇
Lucia: Hey, did we just find a buddy for this snake?
Lucia: 已经找到了一个小伙伴
Lucia: We've already found a buddy for it.
Tasha: 对蛇跟那个熊猫哎
Tasha: Right, the snake and the panda, huh.
Tasha: 怎么怎么怎么弄来着
Tasha: How did we do that again?
Lucia: 啊对对对
Lucia: Ah, right, right, right.
Alice: 有人长这样吗
Alice: Does anyone look like this?
Lucia: 好像不太有人长这样
Lucia: Doesn't seem like anyone looks like this.
Lucia: 嗯好像也不是呢
Lucia: Hmm, seems like it's not either.
Jake: 把它弄一边长是吧
Jake: Make it grow on one side, right?
Jake:那把它竖过来倒过来
Jake: Then turn it vertically, upside down.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Tasha: 就还剩最后的
Tasha: So there's just the last one left.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Tasha: 这这两个也没找着家是吗
Tasha: These two haven't found their place either, right?
Tasha: 还剩最后5个没找着家的
Tasha: There are still five that haven't found their place.
Tasha: 要不尝试着把它们把这些放进去吧
Tasha: How about we try putting these in?
Tasha: 说不定形状就出来了
Tasha: Maybe the shape will come out.
Shure:  都行其实嗯
Shure: Anything's fine, actually.
Shure:  也别太长
Shure: Don't make it too long.
Shure:  别比那个黑板
Shure: Don't go past the blackboard.
Lucia: 这怎么放能让他不不位移
Lucia: How can we place this so it doesn't move?
Jake:这样呗
Jake: Like this.
Shure:  这个还是高嗯
Shure: This one is still high, hmm.
Jake: 这个高一点
Jake: This one is a bit higher.
Shure:  再高一点点这个
Shure: A little higher, this one.
Shure:  啊过了
Shure: Ah, it's over.
Shure:  过了过了
Shure: Over, over.
Shure:  OK OK好
Shure: OK, OK, good.
Shure:  yes
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  把它拼上对
Shure: Put it together, right.
Shure:  good good good
Shure: Good, good, good.
Alice: 这俩像在一块吗
Alice: Do these two look like they go together?
Shure:  人类的智慧
Shure: Human wisdom.
Tasha: 像又不太像
Tasha: They look like it, but not really.
Lucia: 这个好像
Lucia: This one looks like it.
Lucia: 是不是很像在一起啊
Lucia: Doesn't it look like they go together?
Lucia: 这俩
Lucia: These two.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 然后这个如果还在这的话就是这样
Lucia: And if this one is still here, it goes like this.
Shure:  师傅你是干什么工作的
Shure: Master, what do you do for a living?
Jake: 修空调的
Jake: I fix air conditioners.
Lucia: 接下来这里还缺一个
Lucia: Next, there's still one missing here.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Jake: 这个怎么看起来很短
Jake: Why does this one look so short?
Lucia: 是谁呢
Lucia: Who is it?
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  OK的OK
Shure: It's OK, OK.
Tasha: 我们已经越来越接近真相了
Tasha: We are getting closer to the truth.
Jake:OK的
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 越来越有拼下去的动力了
Tasha: Getting more motivated to finish this.
Tasha: 还有3个人无家可归
Tasha: 这个感觉这个小家伙在哪都行
Tasha: This little guy feels like he fits anywhere.
Shure:  嗯你要找好那个
Shure: Hmm, you need to find that.
Alice:超过盘了哦
Alice: Exceeded the limit.
Jake: 不行
Jake: No good.
Lucia: 啊，对不起
Lucia: Ah, sorry.
Shure:  然后上面就可以，进行下一半
Shure: Then the top can proceed to the next half.
Lucia: 这个猫好像不在这里
Lucia: It seems like the cat isn't here.
Jake: 但是你可以把六边形给找着
Katrina:  吓我一跳
Katrina: That scared me.
Shure:  给人犯法
Shure: That's illegal.
Shure:  完了
Shure: It's over.
Lucia: 那好像又不是真想要完全放进去
Lucia: It doesn't seem like they really want to put it all in.
Katrina: 这是啥呀
Tasha: 可是就是会有点边角的
Tasha: But there will be some corners.
Tasha: 我感觉
Tasha: I feel.
Katrina: 甜品啊，那个是不是
Lucia: 哎是是是
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿
Tasha: Hehehe.
Alice: 我感觉这个不对了
Alice: I feel like this is wrong.
Lucia: 这个地方塞进去了
Lucia: This part is in.
Lucia: 不对那这个肯定在这
Lucia: No, this must go here.
Tasha: 可能不清
Tasha: Maybe it's not clear.
Alice:这个头吗
Alice: This head, right?
Katrina:  这给我看刚刚这个
Katrina: Show me that one just now.
Katrina:  刚刚这个是归谁吗
Katrina: Who did that one belong to?
Tasha: 这个不归谁
Tasha: It didn't belong to anyone.
Katrina: 啊行
Katrina: Oh, okay.
Shure: 完了
Shure: It's over.
Alice: 哎不对啊
Tasha: 啊对对对，他们仨是归着的
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, yeah, those three belong together.
Lucia: 然后这还有一组这还有一组
Lucia: And then there's another set here.
Alice: 这个这个有归家吗
Alice: Does this one have a group?
Lucia: 刚才咱是不是他和熊猫也是女生
Katrina: 这应该是那个平台吧
Shure:  他是加黑板
Shure: He's on the blackboard.
Lucia: 不是他是蛇是蛇
Lucia: No, he's a snake, a snake.
Lucia: 那这个豹子
Lucia: And this leopard.
Shure: 他俩应该不是不穿一起
Shure: They probably shouldn't be together.
Lucia: 这豹子这个平平的面很好找呀
Lucia: This leopard is easy to find with this flat surface.
Katrina:  这里哦这里有六边形
Katrina: Here, oh, here's a hexagon.
Jake: 不对
Jake: No, wrong.
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Katrina: 这俩
Katrina:  干啥
Katrina: What are they doing?
Alice:这里这样子的
Alice: It's like this here.
Katrina: 那是卡扣吗
Tasha: 那这还直
Tasha: This is still straight.
Tasha: 这正好还差一个边
Tasha: There's just one more side missing.
Alice: 对你说的那个平平的是不是这个
Alice: Right, is that flat one you're talking about this one?
Lucia: 他们他们有点
Lucia: They, they are kind of
Lucia: 有点像边
Lucia: Kind of like the edge
Shure: 我想想看
Shure: Let me think about it
Katrina: 高度调整
Jake:比划比划要不
Shure: 我想想啊
Jake: 应该这样
Jake:应该这么放
Jake:它是不是这么卡着
Katrina: 使用开关紧固连接高度调节
Lucia: 这现在这些个编的顺序我们拼的
Lucia: Now these sequences we arranged
Lucia: 不一定是
Lucia: Aren't necessarily
Shure: 别的
Shure: Other
Katrina:  他是怎么卡出黑板的
Shure: 好像真的有一个接着它的
Jake: 这个
Jake: This
Lucia: 也有一点
Lucia: Also a bit
Lucia: 放进去试试
Lucia: Try putting it in
Alice: 哎对
Alice: Oh right
Lucia: 那这里需要卡吗
Lucia: Do we need to clip it here?
Shure:  智慧
Shure: Wisdom
Katrina: 放哪
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey
Lucia: 我刚刚哦这样接近真相了啊这
Lucia: I just, oh, getting close to the truth here, this
Tasha: 3个都是
Jake: 牛逼
Jake: Awesome
Jake:确实 牛逼
Katrina:  哇一下变得很正规
Lucia: 像像挨着这个的
Lucia: Like, like next to this
Jake: 那把这个加低一点
Jake: Then lower this a bit
Lucia: 挨着这里挨着这里
Lucia: Next to here, next to here
Lucia: 呃，推一下这里
Lucia: Uh, push here
Katrina: 放哪呢放这
Alice:他俩拼到了
Alice: They pieced it together
Lucia: 他俩拼到了
Lucia: They pieced it together
Lucia: 哎呀，刚刚那个呢
Lucia: Oh no, where did that one go?
Jake:往下往下
Tasha: 好好好真相只有一个
Tasha: Alright, alright, there's only one truth
Lucia: 啊，我，我
Lucia: Ah, I, I
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 怎么回事
Lucia: What's going on?
Jake: 就是往下
Jake: Just going down
Jake: 下不来对
Jake: Can't get down, right
Lucia: 这好像还挺像的
Lucia: This looks quite similar
Lucia: 有可能是动
Lucia: It might be moving
Shure:  太牛了我们
Shure: We're too awesome
Lucia: 接下来的这一边
Lucia: Next to this side
Shure: 拼好了
Shure: Pieced it together
Jake: 他俩是一
Jake: They are a
Shure:  这是粉笔他俩他俩是一家的
Shure: This is chalk, they, they are a family
Jake: 放哪了太牛了
Jake: Where did you put it? This is amazing.
Lucia: 可以有点像
Lucia: It could be a bit like this.
Tasha: 他们应该都这这
Katrina: 好看类还有艺术的感觉
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Lucia:然后这个是在
Lucia: And then this is at...
Jake: 几点睡的
Tasha: 是一对的呀
Tasha: They are a pair.
Katrina:  1点
Lucia: 就这这   Shure: 1点多
Lucia: Just like this. Shure: A bit past 1.
Jake: 几点醒的
Katrina:  10点
Tasha: 只有这个边和这个边位
Tasha: Only this side and this side.
Tasha: 人类是这样的
Tasha: Humans are like this.
Shure:  七点醒
Shure: Woke up at 7.
Alice: 你五点半才睡
Alice: You didn't sleep until 5:30.
Katrina:  出门吗上楼   Jake:上楼
Katrina: Going out? Going upstairs? Jake: Going upstairs.
Jake: 没有   Shure: 没有
Katrina:  去看看
Jake: 下午会有人带我们去做
Jake: In the afternoon, someone will take us to do it.
Katrina:  我没看到
Katrina: I didn't see it.
Shure:  旁边楼上比我们好像热一点
Katrina:  楼上不通风  Lucia: 这个做不出来这个地方
Katrina: Upstairs isn't ventilated. Lucia: This place can't be done.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:那怎么通
Jake: Then how to ventilate?
Alice: 现在脑子有点转不动
Alice: My brain isn't working now.
Lucia: 但这个其实也还蛮像的   Shure: 是的
Lucia: But this actually looks quite similar. Shure: Yes.
Alice: 咋拼来着
Tasha: 这个和谁是一家来着
Tasha: This and who are a family?
Katrina:  姐姐会来吗
Katrina: Will sister come?
Katrina:  那个短头发
Lucia: 可能是这这这
Lucia: Maybe it's this, this, this.
Katrina:  他们要实验室上班是吧
Katrina: They work in the lab, right?
Jake: 打完卡就可以了
Jake: 然后他也不一定
Katrina:  他们昨天晚上那么晚走
Shure:  12点大左右
Shure: Around 12 o'clock.
Jake: 夜生活刚开始吧
Jake: 如果没有这些事的话
Katrina:  他开车的应该还好是吧
Katrina: He should be fine driving, right?
Jake: 我们如果布置二楼的话
Shure:  什么
Jake:如果布置这个二楼
Jake: 因为我们活动场地有可能在这
Lucia:  怎么还少一块啊
Lucia: Why is there still a piece missing?
Katrina: 就是介绍产品，包括他们自我介绍在这里。
Jake: 然后场地可能要搞一个耶耶
Jake: Then we might need to make a space, yeah.
Lucia: 胜利近在眼前
Lucia: Victory is close at hand.
Alice: 他们到这这啊
Alice: They're here, here.
Alice: 哇天才
Alice: Wow, genius.
Lucia: 那我觉得那个鹰翅膀就是在这里Alice:放进去放进去放进去
Lucia: Then I think the eagle wings should be here.
Lucia: 稍等，我们比划比划
Lucia: Hold on, let's measure it.
Shure:  哎我们随手拿的咖啡放哪里来着
Lucia: 然后鹰翅放在这啊
Lucia: And then the eagle wings go here.
Shure:  在这呢
Lucia: 哈哈哈不行
Lucia: Hahaha, no way.
Katrina: 哎呀 拼成了吗
Alice: 来我们录一下这个数据
Alice: Come on, let's record this data.
Jake: 咖啡味已经出来了呢
Jake: The coffee aroma is already coming out.
Lucia: 哈哈哈快来快来
Lucia: Hahaha, come on, come on.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:来了来了来了来了来了
Jake: Coming, coming, coming, coming, coming.
Lucia: 拼好了哈哈哈
Lucia: It's assembled, hahaha.
Jake: 好强啊
Lucia: 太不容易了
Jake: 太强了
Jake: So strong.
Jake:应该  半个多小时
Jake:这个到时候送个客人还有点脸面
Jake: 就我们拼好然后你们再来拼
Jake: We'll assemble it, then you guys can try.
Lucia: 应该，没了就这点啊
Lucia: Should be, that's all we have.
Alice: 啊，那
Alice: Ah, then...
Jake:这个也可以研究一会
Jake: We can study this for a bit too.
Jake: 那这个是不是可以
Jake: Then, can this be...
Lucia: 那那是他俩互相掐一点
Lucia: That, that, they pinch a bit here.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:放平吧要不行
Lucia: 对然后就这样子夹住
Lucia: Yes, then just clamp it like this.
Katrina: 稳定的三角型结构
Jake: 可以
Jake: It's fine.
Lucia: 为了防止它散还可以就先装进来
Lucia: To prevent it from scattering, we can just assemble it first.
Jake: 挺强
Lucia: 哎把这一边朝着另外那一边
Lucia: Hey, turn this side towards the other side.
Alice: 这样头挤着屁股的这种
Jake: 看一看有多和谐
Jake: see how harmonious it is.
Lucia: 和谐共处哦
Lucia: Harmonious coexistence.
Jake: 就熊猫后面他很开心的感觉
Jake: The panda at the back looks so happy.
Lucia: 哈哈哈是吗
Lucia: Hahaha, really?
Alice: 就是找那种你看像这种比较紧密的
Alice: Look for something like this, more closely packed.
Lucia: 对对对就是差不多最后拼起来
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, just about the final assembly.
Lucia: 你看一下
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我不敢想象
Tasha: I can't imagine.
Tasha: 哈哈哈客人可能拼一拼就
Tasha: Hahaha, the customer might just...
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I...
Jake:你有好的东西要不给我们秀一秀
Jake: Do you have anything good to show us?
Lucia: 哎我的刚才
Lucia: Hey, just now...
Tasha: 不用吧Lucia: 哦在这
Tasha: No need, right? Lucia: Oh, here it is.
Tasha: 这是做蛋糕的模具
Tasha: These are cake molds.
Tasha: 裱花嘴
Tasha: Piping tips.
Tasha: 打蛋器搅拌棒
Jake: 明白明白
Jake: Got it, got it.
Lucia: 饮料应该也行
Jake: 30306090120是吧一盒30 卖的话是吗
Jake: 30, 60, 90, 120, right? A box of 30, for sale, right?
Tasha: 定价啊定价一般15
Tasha: Pricing, pricing, usually 15.
Tasha:  这个是送的哦
Tasha:  this one is a free gift.
Tasha: 你要最量
Tasha: You want the maximum.
Jake: 呃这边
Shure:  摆摆桌子上扬的让娃找纸找不到
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Lucia: 哎呀幸好外面有一层对
Lucia: Oh, luckily there's an outer layer.
Tasha: 打蛋器
Alice: 削皮刀
Tasha: 放这呗这我觉得应该放烤箱上面
Tasha: Just put it here, I think it should be on top of the oven.
Jake: 你买烤箱了
Jake: You bought an oven?
Tasha: 烤箱温度计
Tasha: oven thermometer.
Lucia: 黑巧吗
Katrina:  好专业
Alice: 提拉米苏的叉
Tasha: 嗯这伯爵红茶包这些东
Tasha: Uh-huh, these Earl Grey tea bags, these things...
Jake: 西昨天应该都扫一遍
Jake: We should have cleaned everything yesterday.
Jake: 扫一天Tasha: 可可粉
Jake: Sweep all day. Tasha: Cocoa powder.
Tasha: 咖啡酒
Katrina:  你会调酒吗
Katrina: Do you know how to mix drinks?
Shure:  我啊嗯
Shure: Me? Uh, yeah
Jake: 看起来会一点
Jake: Looks like you know a bit
Jake: 哈哈哈Shure: 可以会可以会我
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 我看要什么材料搜一下
Katrina: 咱有多少个杯子啊，一共
Shure:  有上面6个下面6个12个
Jake: 我靠这什么
Jake: Whoa, what's this?
Katrina:  咱都是他的助手
Katrina: 买点柠檬片Jake:非常有用
Katrina: Buy some lemon slices
Katrina:  我来记一下
Katrina: I'll write it down
Jake: 嗯对下午要买东西就记一下菜单吧
Jake: Yeah, if we need to buy stuff in the afternoon, just write it down on the menu
Shure:  这白板拍一下拍
Shure: Take a picture of this whiteboard
Jake: 拍完了然后擦
Jake: Take a picture and then erase it
Jake: 再拍一下擦掉吧
Jake: Take another picture and erase it
Shure:  我刚拍了还有
Shure: I just took a picture, there's more
Jake: 嗯对就这么拍
Tasha: 淀粉
Jake:我记住你了
Katrina: 还要买点养乐多
Alice: 大手套都可以买点饮料
Alice: Big gloves, we can also buy some drinks
Jake: 这啥呀酒
Jake: What's this, alcohol?
Jake: 可以要啥酱吗
Jake: Do you need any sauces?
Katrina: 真的吗
Lucia: 这个怎么用啊
Lucia: How do you use this?
Katrina: 然后这个冰…把这个固定器冷冻还是有冷藏
Tasha: 就是你把这个固定器
Shure:  其实也可以
Shure: It can actually work
Alice: 然后就把这两个固定就固定在第几层
Alice: Then just fix these two, which layer are you setting it on?
Katrina: 外卖点冰吗不是去前面咖啡店要点冰
Tasha: 然后呢用这个刀这样横着过去
Tasha: Then use this knife to cut horizontally like this
Shure:  哎不是再往下一个
Shure: No, go down one more
Katrina: 幻觉
Katrina:  如果超市里有的
Katrina: 养乐多
Tasha: 嗯糯米粉
Tasha: Hmm, glutinous rice flour
Tasha: 两勺没了哇
Tasha: Two scoops, it's gone
Katrina: 伏特加
Lucia: 哎这个水是没开的吧
Lucia: Hey, this water isn't boiled, right?
Lucia: 有点渴
Lucia: I'm a bit thirsty
Lucia: 这瓶好像没开过
Lucia: This bottle seems unopened
Lucia: 这瓶没开这瓶没开过
Lucia: This bottle isn't opened, it's unopened
Katrina: 这个好好看
Lucia: 有道理
Lucia: Makes sense
Lucia: 但是如果大家都折了一个角的话
Lucia: But if everyone folds a corner
Alice: 过来有个人是一个撕掉
Alice: Someone comes and tears it off
Shure:  我回宿舍
Shure: I'm heading back to the dorm
Lucia: 我把外面就撕下来
Lucia: I'll tear off the outer part
Lucia: 给他叠个花
Lucia: Fold a flower for him.
Jake: 就在这写个
Katrina:  你今天晚上回宿舍啊
Lucia: 笔在这里
Lucia: The pen is here.
Katrina: 你毕设这么早吗
Shure:  很奇怪啊
Shure: It's so strange.
Lucia: 你们还有模拟答辩
Lucia: You guys still have a mock defense?
Shure:  好
Shure:okay.
Jake: 点外卖了吗
Jake: Did you order takeout?
Tasha: 还没吃午饭吗
Tasha: Haven't had lunch yet?
Lucia: 对，现在几点了
Lucia: Yeah, what time is it now?
Jake: 一点不饿是吧Lucia: 一点半了
Jake: Not hungry, Lucia? It's 1:30.
Jake: 点个外卖
Jake: Let's order some takeout.
Jake:对吧现在点一下
Jake: 拉倒了
Tasha: 就是在一楼做是吗
Tasha: On the first floor, right?
Tasha: 哦我就是忘了
Katrina: 咖啡是怎么做的，就是把那个粉倒进去
Jake: 对是
Jake: 全是礼物
Jake : It's all gifts.
Shure:  谢谢全
Shure: Thanks for everything.
Tasha: 开放的
Katrina: 那如果哪一天给大家做咖啡用那个就行
Jake: 这边是会议室和厨房合理吧
Jake: This side is the meeting room and kitchen, makes sense, right?
Katrina: 咖啡机要多少钱
Shure:  咖啡机就要很大的钱
Katrina: 哎呀那算了
Lucia: 我还以为是我们戴的这个太像了
Lucia: I thought we were wearing the same thing.
Lucia: 只有一面
Jake: 对可以用粉笔写啊
Jake: Yeah, you can write with chalk on it.
Lucia: 对这个是这备用的一套是吗
Lucia: Right, this is the spare set, right?
Tasha: 我靠啊小心手
Tasha: Watch out, be careful with your hand.
Jake: 咖啡整很好了是吧
Jake: The coffee turned out pretty good, right?
Shure:  咖啡好像没有那么多
Shure: Seems like there's not much coffee left.
Jake: 哦哦而且只只能手冲
Jake: Oh, and we can only make pour-over coffee.
Jake: 哈哈哈一小杯
Shure:  咖啡也按烧腾喝是吧
Shure: You drink coffee boiling hot, right?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure:  直接烧腾浓缩
Shure: Just boiling hot and concentrated.
Lucia: 我刚开始点是不会点
Lucia: Haha, at first, I didn't know how to order.
Lucia: 真的点过一烧腾
Lucia: Really, you ordered it boiling hot?
Jake: 看一看Shure: 吃的点什么
Jake: Let's take a look. Shure: What are we ordering to eat?
Shure:  美团外卖送啥都快
Shure: Meituan delivery is always fast.
Lucia:哦OK
Tasha: 他是用来干嘛的
Tasha: what's he using it for?
Jake: 打空气的
Katrina:  我记一下我要买啥
Shure:  哈哈哈
Jake: 自己都没记住
Jake: Hahaha, you didn't even remember yourself.
Lucia: 我就听到一个KFC
Lucia: I only heard KFC.
Lucia: 不不不我只是只记得这个
Lucia: No, no, no, I just remembered that.
Lucia: 因为太快了
Lucia: Because it was too fast.
Katrina: 可以吃肯德基汉堡王
Jake: 汉堡王啊
Jake: Burger King?
Lucia: 我我没有忌口
Lucia, I don't have any dietary restrictions.
Katrina:  我想吃那奥尔良烤翅
Katrina: I want to eat that Orleans-style, I'm going crazy.
Jake: 好那就
Jake: 尊享无敌
Jake: Supreme enjoyment.
Alice: 用之前记得刷一遍Shure: 披萨
Alice: Remember to wash it before using. Shure: Pizza.
Jake: 下面全是肉的披萨
Jake: The pizza is all meat underneath.
Jake: 炸鸡炸鸡